bonjour karine monségur merci de
répondre à nos questions sur arte france
dans quel état d'esprit est ce que vous
êtes ce matin avant cette journée
cruciale colère et résignation
bonjour monsieur sommes évidemment très
en colère et très scandalisée par le
fait que l'argent qui est consenti à air
france va servir finalement à envoyer
des milliers de salariés vers pôle
emploi
or nous considérons à la cgt que cet
argent les 3 milliards de l'état qui
sont faits un taux de prêt exorbitant du
droit commun et les 4 milliards de prêts
bancaires devraient prioritairement
servir à la préservation des emplois
notamment par le système de chômage
partiel qui est mis en classe et peut
être étendu à un horizon de 24 mois il
n'est absolument pas acceptable et nous
n'allons pas nous laisser faire
ni air france ni hao de voir qu'encore
une fois ce sont les salariés et leurs
familles qui vont payer une crise dont
ils ne sont en rien responsables
vous parlez des 17 milliards d'euros
qui selon vous donc voir les pour pour
pôle emploi
de son côté jean baptiste djebbari dans
le sujet doit l'y des bananes et on l'a
vu à déclare que les 7 milliards d'euros
se sont pour payer les salaires et donc
du coup conservé certains emplois face à
julien bayou qui est de son côté estime
que les contribuables financent les
licenciements qui croire au final
monsieur djebbari n'est pas très bien
renseignés parce que comment peut-il a
argué que l'argent va servir à la
préservation des emplois quand dans le
même temps ce matin vont être annoncées
pour air france et hop
des milliers de suppressions d'emplois
nous avons fait le calcul au niveau de
la cgt cela va concerner 8000 à 300
salariés
alors il y aura un plan de départs
volontaires auquel succédera notamment
pour le court courrier et hop
un ps donc si la volonté du gouvernement
était vraiment de sauvegarder les
emplois et bien les annonces de ce matin
n'aurait pas lieu
les avions sont quand même restés cloués
au sol pendant trois mois est ce que
vous comprenez les pertes liées au
confinement et quels sacrifices c'est ce
que vous êtes prête à faire je comprends
nous qu'on peut nous ont des pertes
alliées au confinement ce que nous ne
comprenons pas c'est qu'à chaque fois
qu'il ya une crise c'est à nous de la
payer
ça fait depuis 2008 la crise de 2008
on nous a expliqué que pour survivre il
fallait tailler dans les effectifs
je rappelle encore une fois que depuis
2009 nous avons supprimé 13 mille
emplois que chaque emploi air france
induit trois à quatre suppressions
d'emplois dans les filiales ou la sous
traitance et tout ceci est inacceptable
on en a marre de toujours devoir payer
les crises c'est toujours aux salariés
de faire des sacs ni piste on ne voit
pas quels sacrifices sont faits du côté
du medef et du côté du patronat
manifestations attendues ce matin devant
le siège de la compagnie à quoi est ce
que vous attendez en termes de
mobilisation d'influencé est ce que vous
pensez que cette manifestation peut
faire fléchir justement le patronat
comme vous dites là faire fléchir la
position de la direction d'air france
alors écoutez la peau la cgt nous
appelons dans 150 entreprises de la
plate forme de roissy et puis à orly je
pense qu'il s'agit aujourd'hui de
s'organiser pour enclencher un mouvement
d'ailleurs nous appelons toutes celles
et ceux qui veulent sauver l'emploi à
entrer dans la lutte et nous nous
considérons qu'aujourd'hui il s'agit de
partager avec l'ensemble des salariés de
la plate forme de roissy et d'orly
les annonces qui vont être faites de
sorte que nous puissions nous organiser
pour ne pas subir une chose est sûre en
ce qui concerne la cgt nous n'allons pas
en rester là et nous n'allons pas subir
les orientations qu'ils sont
aujourd'hui retenue qui était d'ailleurs
déjà décidé depuis quelques temps mais
qui sont accélérées pour casser le socle
social au niveau d'air france et à terme
remplacer les emplois d'air france par
des emplois de la sous traitance
quand vous dites vous ne voulez pas ça
vous ne voulez pas subir quelles actions
à ce que vous envisagez à écouter c'est
une construction qui doit se faire avec
avec les salariés avec les organisations
syndicales qui seront dans les luttes
je n'ai je n'ai pas ce stade d'idée
précise de ce que nous mettrons en
oeuvre les camarades de up se
rassemblent aujourd'hui à nantes où va
se tenir le cs dans lequel vont être
annoncées 1300 suppressions d'emplois
est ce que nous allons essayer de faire
c'est de créer une convergence des
luttes à la fois dans le transport
aérien mais pas seulement parce que ce
sont toutes les entreprises qui
aujourd'hui sont concernés par les
attaques faites au manque du travail et
il est plus qu urgent que le monde du
travail s'organise pour inverser les
infléchir les orientations du medef et
du patronat
ces mots de la fin merci car elles m'ont
ses yeux d'avoir répondu à nos questions
je rappelle que vous êtes à la co
secrétaire général de la cgt air france